après plus de 200 matchs et 429 joueurs
passer sur les courts
ils n'étaient plus que deux à se
disputer le titre de l'open d'elancourt
ce week-end dans ce duel de gauchers
rudy coco 42e joueur français en 2012 et
est logiquement le favori pour le titre
le gaucher valdoisiens fait tout de
suite parler sa puissance pour briquer
le champion du monde des plus de 35 ans
xavier audouy il empoche le premier set
6 gbits très offensif et fort d'un coup
droit surpuissant le val d'oisien est un
habitué des surfaces rapides et cela se
voit coco en poche la seconde manche 6-4
et son deuxième titre élan courtois il a
eu raison de vaincre les embouteillages
franciliens j'étais je pense un petit
peu plus constant par rapport à lui
genre d'homme dans mes frappes de balle
j'ai été un peu plus régulier et je
pense j'étais un peu plus puissant dans
certains moments clés du jeu qui ont su
faire la différence après elle encore
rudy coco va retrouver le circuit atp
dès la semaine prochaine
direction l'espagne et le portugal pour
retrouver le top 500 mondial